Alright, so we've talked about how you
can clone a repository so you can work
on it in your own development
environment. Just in case you're
interested in working in the with the
command line a little bit, here are some
of the more common commands that you
would use with Git. Now, these are just my
opinion and you will need a lot more
commands than just this, but this will
get you off to a good start. 'git clone' is
what we talked about earlier this is how
you can clone a repository down to your
local machine. You'll notice all of these
start off with 'git' ("G-I-T") that's an
important piece to remember. Now you
don't have to memorize all of these at
once but I do want to kind of explain
them just a little bit. 'git pull', remember
how we talked about the remote
repository that everyone has their
changes, y'know, uploaded to that? When you run
'git pull' your bringing down the
changes that some of your colleagues
might have made and pushed up to the
remote repository. 'git branch' is how you
create a branch on your local machine.
Remember we don't want to make commits on
master want to create a branch first. We
check out to that branch with 'git checkout'. When we do that we're letting Git
know that any commits that are made we
want them to be on that specific branch.
'git status' is maybe my favorite command
you can run 'git status' at any time and
it will tell you exactly what's going on.
You can use this at any point in time. So
following the GitHub workflow a little
bit we created a branch and we made some
changes and we want to store them as
commits we use 'git add' before we use 'git
commit'. Now,  we'll get into the complexity
of this a little bit on the next video
but it's important to know that it is a
two-step commit. Once you've
made the changes locally you can push
them up to the remote repository just
like you pulled them down with 'git push'.
So again, you don't need to memorize all
of these right now but just a little
introduction so that maybe the command
line isn't so scary.